Aigle du Reich,
drapeau à croix gammée
et défilé au pas de l'oie.
Nous sommes bien en 1940.
Ces images ont été
filmées en France à Paris,
par les soldats
de l'armée allemande, la Wehrmacht.
Pendant les années de guerre,
ils étaient ici chez eux.
Plus de 100 000 soldats,
officiers, généraux.
Des hommes mais aussi des femmes
sont passés par la Ville lumière.
Paris était pour tous,
le rêve ultime.
- Paris, c'était
les plus belles années.
Les parfums, la bonne nourriture
et tous ces monuments à visiter.
- Loin des champs de bataille,
les nouveaux seigneurs
ont fait de Paris un eldorado.
Tout y est pensé pour eux.
L'occupant a su choisir les endroits
les plus agréables et les plus plaisants.
- Ils ne vont pas se mettre
dans un meublé sinistre, c'est clair.
Dans les beaux quartiers,
une deuxième Allemagne.
Foyer, café, cinéma
où l'offre 100 pourcent
allemande est réservée aux soldats.
- Il fallait qu'ils
puissent vivre à l'allemande,
c'était très important.
- Les soldats
jouissent ici sans entraves.
La nuit, cabarets,
théâtres, restaurants
et aussi prostituées
françaises sont à leur disposition.
- Ça m'a permis de profiter
des choses que je n'avais pas chez moi,
les maisons
closes par exemple.
- Pour les Parisiens,
l'occupation allemande entraîne pénuries,
tickets de rationnement,
mais aussi rafles et répression féroce.
- Ça faisait peur,
on ressentait la main de l'occupation.
- Si tout les oppose, Français
et Allemands vont parfois se rapprocher.
De l'hostilité,
certains vont passer à l'amour.
Des histoires comme
celles de Marguerite et Otto
vont même donner
naissance à des enfants.
- Mon père a aimé
très sincèrement ma mère,
ma mère a toujours aimé
mon père et elle en était folle.
- Les aventures parisiennes de ces soldats
ce sont eux-mêmes qui les racontent.
D'abord Klaus,
soldat de la Luftwaffe, l'Armée de l'air.
Gertrud,
opératrice téléphonique.
Puis les enfants de soldats
qui ont entendu leurs histoires
et archivés
photos et documents.
Aujourd'hui, Peter Lorenz,
fils d'un officier haut gradé,
et Margaret Witte,
fille d'un simple soldat,
sont les gardiens
de la mémoire de leurs pères.
- Ils était fasciné
par la vie de cette métropole.
- Il y a aussi
des milliers de journaux intimes,
d'innombrables albums photos,
sans oublier des millions de lettres
envoyées pendant les années
de guerre aux familles.
Autant d'histoires singulières,
de témoignages,
sur ces quatre
années où Paris était allemande.
Qui étaient
ces soldats et officiers ?
Comment vivaient-ils au quotidien
dans la plus belle ville du monde ?
Quelles étaient
les véritables relations
entre les nouveaux seigneurs
et les Parisiens vaincus.
Pour la première fois,
l'occupation de Paris,
racontée par l'autre bout de la lorgnette,
du côté
des soldats allemands.
14 juin 1940, à Paris.
Le temps s'annonce radieux,
mais la capitale est une ville morte.
Les rues, les terrasses de cafés
et les immeubles sont vides.
Sur les 1,8 millions de Parisiens,
plus d'un million ont pris la fuite.
Pour cause, leur pire
cauchemar est en train de devenir réalité.
La Wehrmacht,
l'armée allemande, marche sur la capitale.
Hitler a vaincu la France
grâce à la Blitzkrieg, la guerre éclair,
en seulement cinq
semaines de combat féroce.
Bilan, 80 000 soldats morts.
À quelques
kilomètres de Paris,
les troupes victorieuses
font une dernière halte.
Le soldat Werner, 18 ans,
originaire de Basse-Saxe, se souvient.
- Avant d'entrer dans la ville,
il fallait nettoyer nos véhicules
et aussi nos uniformes.
Il fallait se présenter
comme des soldats soignés.
On devait
faire bonne impression.
- C'est par le Nord,
portes de Clignancourt et de la Villette
que les premières
unités arrivent.
- Les premières unités
arrivent à Paris vers 6 h du matin.
Ce sont des unités de moto.
Elles se dirigent
vers la place de la Concorde.
Ça deviendra un endroit central
pour le haut commandement allemand.
Les Allemands ne rencontrent
aucune résistance à Paris.
- Paris, la Ville lumière
vient de tomber aux mains du Reich.
Une belle prise et le point d'orgue
d'une campagne victorieuse.
Le soldat Klaus avait 19 ans
à l'époque et il mesure sa chance.
- J'étais content d'être à Paris,
c'est ce qui pouvait m'arriver de mieux.
Je suis Berlinois,
je connais les grandes villes,
Paris, c'est encore
une classe au dessus.
Ici, je pouvais vivre
sans risquer ma vie.
Ici, je n'étais plus
en danger de mort.
- Prochaine étape
pour les troupes de la Wehrmacht,
établir leur
quartier militaire.
Dans une ville désertée
par deux tiers de ses habitants,
les conditions sont idéales.
Les grands hôtels sont vides
et la plupart des appartements aussi.
Pour éviter les combats,
Paris a été déclarée ville ouverte
par les autorités françaises.
Cela signifie qu'elles doivent
se plier aux exigences des vainqueurs.
Alors les Allemands
ont carte blanche.
- Le meilleur guide était le guide
Michelin, qui est traduit en allemand.
Le guide Michelin,
le guide rouge de 1939.
Quels sont les meilleurs
endroits et hôtels ?
L'occupant a su donc choisir
les endroits les plus agréables,
les plus plaisants
et les plus emblématiques de Paris.
Ce sont des symboles,
mais bien évidemment,
ils ne vont pas se mettre
dans un meublé sinistre, c'est clair.
- Ces hôtels réquisitionnés
sont tous très prestigieux.
À commencer par le Meurice rue de Rivoli,
siège du général Schaumburg,
le nouveau maître de Paris.
Le Ritz place Vendôme,
le plus prestigieux palace de la ville,
est réservé aux hauts
dignitaires en visite à Paris.
Le maréchal Hermann Göering,
commandant de l'Armée de l'air,
y a une suite
réservée à l'année.
Rive gauche, l'hôtel Lutetia,
le plus moderne
de tous les palaces parisiens.
Il devient le siège de l'Abwehr,
les services secrets allemands.
Le plus important de tous,
le Majestic.
Cet hôtel abrite le MBF,
le haut commandement
militaire pour toute la France.
À sa tête,
le général Otto Von Stülpnagel.
- À chaque fois, c'est un symbole,
l'Arc de triomphe, ce n'est pas rien.
L'avenue d'Iéna, tous ces noms
qui sont des victoires de Napoléon
et c'est aussi
la revanche, la revanche.
- Pour garantir une sécurité
maximale à ces endroits ultrasensibles,
les services secrets nazis
se procurent les plans précis.
- Des plans du cadastre
étaient en vente libre
et ces plans indiquent toujours
la portes d'entrée, la porte de sortie.
C'est pour en cas d'attaque,
toujours une possibilité de s'enfuir.
Bien évidemment,
les lieux de réquisition
se sont faits en fonction de
ces possibilités, toujours de fuite.
Plus un lieu
occupé est important,
plus il comporte une, deux,
voire trois portes de sortie.
- Les officiers n'auront pas
à se plaindre de leur logement.
Le George V,
le Raphaël, le Crillon,
le Royal Monceau et d'autres
adresses de prestige leur sont réservées.
Question de confort,
mais pas seulement.
- Chaque chambre
est équipée de téléphone.
Non seulement
on pouvait loger tout le monde,
mais on avait
aussi l'infrastructure.
Ce qui était essentiel,
c'était d'avoir l'électricité
et le contrôle
des centraux téléphoniques.
Comme les hôtels n'ont que des lits,
il faut ensuite des bureaux,
des lampes,
des machines à écrire.
Les Allemands dressent donc
des listes interminables de demandes
que les Français
doivent satisfaire.
- Alors comment ça marche ?
Prenons l'exemple du Majestic
avec ses suites de grand luxe.
Premier étage, la chambre 119
est devenue le bureau d'un lieutenant
chargé de gérer
les permissions des soldats.
Juste à côté, l'ex-chambre 118,
elle, est transformée en secrétariat.
La 117 sert maintenant à l'enregistrement
des soldats fraîchement arrivés.
Quelques étages
plus haut, au quatrième,
l'ex-suite 464 est devenue
le bureau du docteur Michel.
Il est chargé de contrôler toute
l'économie de la France en zone allemande.
Les plus hautes instances
militaires y sont conviées.
La décoration
est simple et spartiate,
un portrait d'Hitler et c'est tout,
rigueur militaire oblige.
En tout, les Allemands
réquisitionneront 400 hôtels à Paris.
Les propriétaires de ces hôtels
n'auront pas à se plaindre.
L'occupant règle sa note,
mais avec de l'argent français.
C'est à la France de payer
les frais de l'occupation allemande,
400 millions de francs,
soit 160 millions d'euros tous les jours.
- Ils mettent en place
un compte bancaire
sur lequel l'État français va verser
400 millions de francs quotidiennement.
C'est avec ce compte que
les Allemands vont financer l'occupation.
Les hôtels, mais aussi
des livraisons à destination du Reich.
L'Allemagne règle ses factures,
mais avec l'argent français.
- Pour leurs besoins,
les Allemands mettent
la main sur des appartements,
voire des immeubles entiers.
Celui de la très prestigieuse
banque britannique Lloyds de Londres
qui devient la caisse
de crédit du Reich.
Puis sur les immeubles et appartements
des juifs parisiens qui ont fui les nazis
et pas question,
bien sûr de payer un loyer.
- Si vous êtes Juif,
franc-maçon, Anglais et Américain,
vous n'avez pas le droit
de posséder les appartements vides.
Il y a donc des spoliations,
des réquisitions, des mises sous scellés.
Ces appartements, on les appelait
les appartements des Juifs, c'est connu.
Les hôtels particuliers
de Rothschild, par exemple.
- L'hôtel particulier
Rothschild sur l'avenue Foch,
devient le siège de la Sipo-SD,
connue sous le nom de Gestapo
et des redoutables SS,
les escadrons de sécurité.
C'est le bras
armé du parti nazi,
connu pour sa cruauté
impitoyable envers les ennemis du Reich.
- Chaque fois,
ce lieu est retourné,
on retourne un endroit
avec une nouvelle finalité.
- Pour l'instant,
les SS et la Sipo-SD
ne font que prendre
leurs marques discrètement.
Le vrai pouvoir est entre
les mains de la Wehrmacht,
l'armée allemande,
mais seulement pour l'instant.
Aux hôtels
et immeubles réquisitionnés,
s'ajoutent aussi deux hôpitaux,
Lariboisière et la Pitié Salpêtrière,
une clinique dentaire
dans le 13ème arrondissement.
Il y a aussi des casernes,
dont trois en centre-ville,
Prince Eugène,
École militaire et même Polytechnique.
C'est ici qu'on logera les soldats
dans des conditions beaucoup plus simples.
- Certains arrondissements
sont privilégiés
et l'Est de Paris est considéré comme
le quartier rouge, des communistes.
Le 10ème, le 11ème, le 19ème, le 20ème,
là, il y a très peu de présence allemande.
- L'occupant
décrète un couvre-feu.
Personne dans les rues
de Paris à partir de 23 h
et les fenêtres
doivent être obstruées.
Les Allemands veulent une ville
déserte et vue du ciel, invisible la nuit.
Les portes de la capitale
sont mises sous haute surveillance.
Entre blindés et barrages,
tout le monde doit montrer
patte blanche pour rentrer dans Paris.
Les Français, bien sûr,
mais aussi les soldats du Reich.
Le sésame, le Ausweis,
un laissez-passer valable
de quelques heures à plusieurs mois.
Pour l'obtenir, direction
la Kommandantur, place de l'Opéra.
- La Kommandantur est l'équivalent
d'une mairie française,
elle règle toutes les questions
administratives de la vie quotidienne.
Elle délivre les papiers qui nécessitent
une autorisation des Allemands.
Elle fonctionne aussi en point
d'accueil pour les soldats allemands.
Ils trouvent tout ce qu'ils
cherchent à la Kommandantur.
- Pour vraiment s'assurer
que Paris est devenue allemande,
les grands carrefours
de la capitale voient fleurir ces panneaux
pour orienter les troupes
vers des lieux stratégiques,
hôpitaux, casernes et bien sûr
les centres de commandement.
Pendant l'été 40,
Paris est transformée en ville allemande.
Première démonstration
de force des nouveaux seigneurs,
la parade de la victoire
au pied de l'Arc de Triomphe,
10 000 soldats défilent au pas
de l'oie sur une avenue déserte.
- Les unités allemandes
font leur premier défilé de la victoire
non pas sur les Champs-Elysées
comme on le raconte souvent,
mais sur l'avenue Foch.
On le voit d'ailleurs sur les images,
l'Arc de Triomphe est un peu en biais.
Si vous voulez mon avis,
c'était une tentative
pour ne pas trop froisser les Français.
- N'empêche, pour ces hommes,
c'est un grand moment de puissance.
Un jeune soldat
autrichien se souvient.
- On se sentait les maîtres
du monde en traversant Paris.
Je pense que c'était
un sentiment normal pour un soldat.
Nous étions fiers d'avoir
battu les Français aussi rapidement.
- Le meilleur reste à venir,
la capitulation de l'ennemi
héréditaire, dix jours plus tard.
Hitler se déplace
en personne,
il exige que
la reddition des Français
se fasse comme celle
des Allemands 22 ans plus tôt, en 1918.
D'abord le lieu,
la clairière de Rethondes,
près de Compiègne,
à 50 kilomètres au Nord de Paris.
Puis ce wagon
spécialement ressorti d'un musée.
C'est sur cette même table
que Français et Allemands
avaient signé l'armistice
du 11 novembre 1918.
Le Führer triomphe
quelques jours plus tard
avec une visite surprise à Paris,
à 6 heures du matin.
Son seul voyage dans cette ville,
qui le fascine depuis sa jeunesse.
- Il était à la tour Eiffel,
au Trocadéro,
là où on a pris
la fameuse photo de lui.
Ensuite,
il s'est rendu à l'Opéra.
On y trouve même
un concierge qui a les clés
et qui peut faire
une visite à cette délégation.
Pendant cette visite,
Hitler constate
qu'il y a eu des changements
par rapport aux plans
qu'il avait étudiés dans sa jeunesse.
Ces plans de l'Opéra,
il les connaissait
presque par cœur et en effet,
le concierge lui confirme
que des travaux ont été faits.
On voit à quel point
il était fasciné par cette ville.
- Plus tard, Hitler confiera
à son architecte Albert Speer :
« C'était le rêve de ma vie
de pouvoir visiter Paris.
Je me suis souvent
demandé s'il fallait détruire Paris.
Quand nous aurons
reconstruit le nouveau Berlin,
Paris ne sera
plus que son ombre.
Alors pourquoi la détruire ? »
Cette fascination pour la Ville lumière,
Hitler la partage avec Joseph Goebbels,
ministre
de la Propagande nazie.
Pour Goebbels,
Paris sera la ville vitrine du Reich,
l'endroit où il fait bon vivre,
à condition d'être allemand.
- Aux yeux de Goebbels,
Paris devait tenir une place
à part au sein du Reich.
Il a très vite compris
qu'il fallait préserver l'ambiance
et le caractère
unique de cette ville.
Instaurer un ordre
typiquement allemand à Paris,
faire de Paris
un deuxième Berlin,
ce n'était pas
dans l'intérêt des Allemands.
Paris, la ville vitrine,
devait être une attraction pour
les soldats, où vivre des aventures.
- Paris sera la ville
du repos du guerrier
où il pourra oublier
les tourments des champs de bataille.
Si les Allemands
ont gagné la guerre,
vont-ils être capables
de gagner le cœur des Parisiens ?
Fin de l'été 1940.
Avec l'armistice signée, la guerre est bel
et bien finie, du moins en France.
Les troupes de la Wehrmacht deviennent
maintenant des troupes d'occupation.
Petit à petit,
le quotidien se met en place.
- Il y a d'abord les permanents
qui travaillent dans
différentes administrations.
Ils sont entre 20 et 25 000
et ne changent pas très souvent.
À Paris, il n'y a pas
besoin de troupes de combat,
mais il existe tout de même
un contingent de soldats
qui peut être mobilisé
en cas de troubles.
Ensuite,
il y a l'industrie à la périphérie
qui développe
des armes pour les Allemands.
Notamment des chars
et il faut des soldats
pour les essayer.
- Il n'y a pas que des hommes
dans l'armée allemande.
Des jeunes femmes auxiliaires
de la Wehrmacht arrivent en renfort.
Elles font moins
de 10 pourcent des effectifs,
mais participent à l'effort
de guerre en occupant des postes
et en libérant ainsi
des hommes qui rejoignent le front.
Elles sont surtout secrétaires
ou opératrices dans les transmissions.
Les Français leur trouvent tout
de suite un surnom, les souris grises.
Si elles s'engagent,
ce n'est pas forcément
pour des raisons idéologiques.
- L'uniforme était très chic,
c'était un tailleur.
Un tailleur, c'était quelque
chose de très élégant à l'époque.
Alors l'Armée offrait
un tailleur à ces femmes
qu'elles n'auraient
jamais pu se payer.
La plupart d'entre elles
venaient de foyers plutôt modestes
et trouvaient que cet uniforme
était quelque chose de très spécial.
- La guerre leur permet aussi
d'échapper au rôle de mère au foyer
imposé par l'idéologie nazie.
En prime,
elles découvrent le nouvel empire
d'Hitler avec son joyau, Paris.
Quand elles étaient affectées
en Allemagne ou en Autriche,
elles étaient un peu déçues parce
qu'elles voulaient partir à l'étranger.
Parmi les destinations
préférées,
il y avait bien sûr
la France et surtout Paris.
C'était la numéro un Paris,
ville de la mode et de l'amour.
- Parmi elles, il y a Gertrud,
originaire d'un petit
village du Nord de l'Allemagne.
Elle fait partie de ces chanceuses
qui sont affectées à Paris.
Elle a alors 20 ans.
- Je n'avais pas d'idée précise
sur ce qui m'attendait à Paris.
J'étais simplement contente de ne pas
finir dans une usine allemande d'armement.
J'ai été affectée
à la Transport Kommandantur Nord.
- Gertrud arrive en 1940
avec un groupe de 30 filles.
Elles sont logées dans
un hôtel à deux pas de la Madeleine.
À Paris,
tout est nouveau pour elles.
- On était dans une métropole.
La plupart d'entre nous
ne connaissaient pas les grandes villes.
On se sentait étrangères,
un peu perdues.
Il fallait vraiment
se mettre dans la tête
qu'on était maintenant
en France et plus en Allemagne.
Au début, on n'avait pas le droit
de sortir toute seule de notre hôtel.
On nous conduisait
à notre travail.
Nous avions un peu peur,
on ne savait pas comment les Français
allaient réagir à notre présence.
- Comment
les Français vont-ils réagir ?
C'est la préoccupation
de l'État major,
pas question de lâcher
les soldats dans la nature.
Pour son premier
mois de séjour,
le soldat Klaus est consigné
dans une caserne parisienne.
- Nous devions d'abord nous installer
dans notre caserne, à l'École militaire.
Trouver nos marques,
nettoyer nos uniformes.
Le quotidien d'un soldat
est toujours organisé à la minute près.
On vous trouve
toujours des choses à faire.
On ne s'ennuie jamais,
mais on n'avait pas
le droit de sortir tout de suite.
- Les ordres viennent
du Führer en personne,
datant du 18 juin 1940.
« Le soldat doit être un exemple
de l'esprit militaire allemand,
en termes de droiture, de bonne humeur,
de virilité dans toutes les situations. »
En clair,
Hitler ordonne à chaque soldat
de se comporter de manière
correcte avec les Parisiens.
Objectif,
faire de l'ennemi un allié.
- En 1940,
la population française
se sent abandonnée
par son propre gouvernement.
Côté allemand, on s'est rendu compte
que le désespoir et la colère des Français
contre leur État était une occasion
de se présenter sous une bonne lumière.
- Au plus haut niveau,
on scelle un accord en octobre 1940,
quand Hitler rencontre
le maréchal Pétain à Montoire.
Avec cette poignée de main,
le vieux combattant
de Verdun promet officiellement
la collaboration du gouvernement
de Vichy au prochain maître de l'Europe.
Reste maintenant
à gagner le cœur des Parisiens.
Une véritable opération
séduction démarre alors.
Les soldats paradent tous
les jours sur les Champs-Élysées.
Les bottes impeccablement
cirées et dans un ordre parfait.
Puis ce geste
symbolique très fort,
ils viennent se recueillir sur la tombe
du Soldat inconnu sous l'Arc de Triomphe.
Un hommage très calculé.
- Les Allemands avaient la réputation
d'être des barbares surtout en France.
Là, les barbares arrivent,
on découvre qu'ils ne
ressemblaient pas à des barbares
et qu'ils ne se comportaient
pas comme tels.
Qu'ils ne mangeaient
pas de petits enfants non plus,
chose dont on n'était
pas si sûre au début.
Ils avaient
l'aura des vainqueurs,
ils fascinaient tout le monde
sans exception et même les hommes.
On peut comprendre
que l'arrivée de ces soldats
avec leurs uniformes bien taillés,
leurs bottes en cuir sur leurs motos,
était une véritable sensation.
- Sur le perron de l'Opéra de Paris
et dans les jardins publics,
les orchestres militaires
essaient de séduire les Parisiens.
Les cantines de la soupe
populaire nationale socialiste
distribuent de la nourriture
gratuitement aux nécessiteux.
Il y a des anecdotes qui racontent
que les petits garçons français
qui jouaient à la guerre voulaient
tous être des soldats allemands
parce que c'étaient
eux les vainqueurs.
- La propagande
a fait son œuvre.
Alors, à partir de juillet 1940,
les Parisiens reviennent de leur exil.
Parmi eux,
Jean-Claude, Parisien de 19 ans.
Il découvre sa ville
et les nouveaux seigneurs.
On est rentrés à Paris
et je vois encore les affiches
sur lesquelles on voyait un grand soldat
souriant avec un enfant sur les épaules
et il y avait écrit :
« Populations abandonnées,
faites confiance
aux soldats allemands. »
Ça m'avait frappé, on regardait
ça avec une certaine incrédulité.
On ne savait pas du tout.
On est rentrés, tout était calme.
- Les pires craintes
sont dissipées des deux côtés.
Pour les soldats allemands,
l'année 1940
sera celle de tous les plaisirs.
Klaus, le soldat berlinois a enfin
ses premières permissions de sortie.
Ça, c'est Paris et là c'est moi
au premier étage de la tour Eiffel.
On était montés
à pieds au premier étage,
les ascenseurs étaient en panne
et c'était déjà très haut.
- Les souvenirs de Klaus
sont soigneusement rangés
dans un luxueux album
offert par l'Armée du Reich.
Couverture en cuir,
casque à croix gammée
et cette inscription en allemand,
mon service militaire.
Ces petits carnets de voyage,
ils seront des milliers
à les confectionner soigneusement.
Munis d'appareils photo
et de caméras,
les soldats Allemands
embarquent pour des visites guidées
dûment encadrées
par le haut commandement.
Devant le Sacré-Cœur, Notre-Dame,
l'Opéra, le Louvre, les Invalides,
sans oublier le Trocadéro
et la Tour Eiffel,
ils se mettent en scène dans la ville
lumière qui désormais leur appartient.
Ces visites guidées se terminent
de manière hautement symbolique
dans la Galerie
des Glaces du château de Versailles.
Là même où le traité infamant pour
l'Allemagne avait été signé en 1919.
La revanche est parfaite.
- Pour ma part,
je n'appellerais pas ça du tourisme,
ça banalise l'occupation.
On voit bien que les soldats
allemands se mettent en scène
comme les vainqueurs
et les nouveaux seigneurs.
Ça, c'était voulu
par Hitler et Goebbels.
Les soldats devaient prendre des photos
pour témoigner de leur glorieuse victoire
et envoyer
ces photos à la maison
pour expliquer à leurs familles
le bien fondé de cette guerre.
Dans l'album de ce soldat,
les photos et les commentaires
sont sans équivoque.
« Voilà les nouveaux maîtres »,
commente-t-il sur cette photo
prise devant le château de Versailles.
Cette photo de la statue
de Louis XIV décapitée
lui inspire un autre commentaire,
« la France sans tête ».
- Il y a de l'ironie, bien sûr,
mais surtout cette idée
que ce sont eux les nouvelles têtes.
- Encore cet autre
album d'un officier
avec cette photo
prise sur le toit de l'Arc de Triomphe.
La botte sur la balustrade,
la pose du nouveau maître
de Paris est savamment étudiée.
- Dans les pays occupés,
la photo était interdite
à la population civile.
En même temps,
les soldats avaient pour habitude
de confisquer tous les appareils photo.
Les civils n'en avaient plus.
Seuls les Allemands avaient
le droit de prendre des photos
et ils en ont bien profité.
- Pour ces jeunes Allemands,
la vraie curiosité est ailleurs.
Qui sont ces Parisiens ?
- C'était un nouveau
monde pour moi,
mais je ne pouvais pas
parler avec les Français
parce que
je ne parlais pas leur langue.
Alors je restais muet,
les Français restaient muets eux aussi
parce qu'ils ne parlaient pas
un mot d'allemand non plus.
La jeune opératrice
Gertrud tente sa chance
avec ses quelques mots
de français appris à l'école.
Elle commence par le concierge
et les bonnes de son hôtel.
J'ai toujours fait des efforts
pour parler avec eux.
Ils étaient plutôt
réservés qu'autre chose.
Ils avaient
leur fierté nationale.
- Comment vouliez-vous
que les Parisiens m'aiment ?
On les avait vaincus.
Les Français ont accepté leur sort
et moi, j'ai accepté le mien.
On a vécu selon
ce principe comme ça,
chacun de notre côté.
On essayait de faire
comme si on ne les voyait pas.
Dans la rue plusieurs fois,
il nous est arrivé de croiser
des détachements allemands
qui se rendaient
d'un point à un autre.
Quand on les voyait
arriver ostensiblement,
on allait vers les vitrines et on
regardait l'intérieur de ces vitrines,
c'est-à-dire
leur tournant le dos.
- C'est en sortant de son hôtel
que Gertrud découvre un univers différent,
une autre mentalité,
une autre manière de vivre.
- Les Français
sont un peu superficiels,
ils ne prennent pas la vie
au sérieux à l'opposé des Allemands.
- Pour les Allemands,
les Français sont superficiels,
distants, impolis et les Parisiennes
sont l'incarnation du diable.
Dans une lettre à sa femme,
le soldat Ernst s'offusque de leur allure.
« Tu n'en croirais pas tes yeux
en voyant le maudit maquillage
dont les femmes
se barbouillent le visage.
Si mon épouse
faisait de la sorte,
je ferais mes bagages
et je m'en irai sur le champ.
C'est incroyable !
Très souvent,
je dois penser à autre chose,
sinon je suis pris
de violentes nausées.
Ces lèvres rouge vif,
ces visages peints en jaune,
ces sourcils surlignés de noir
et ces vernis à ongles éclatants.
Derrière ce tape à l'œil
se cache une grande cochonnerie. »
- Pour les Allemands,
c'est le choc des cultures.
Les Parisiennes sont si
différentes de l'idéal féminin allemand
prôné par
la propagande du Reich.
Soucieuse
du comportement des troupes,
la Wehrmacht va même consacrer
un chapitre entier aux femmes françaises
dans son guide officiel,
Paris vu par les Allemands.
« La Parisienne est coquette,
même si elle a une tendance
naturelle à jouer de ses atouts féminins,
elle possède un sens de la famille très
fort et un grand amour pour ses enfants. »
- On voulait
éviter les malentendus
en expliquant aux soldats
qu'il y avait d'autres mœurs en France.
Une Française n'est pas
une prostituée ou une fille facile
simplement parce qu'elle ressemble à ce
que serait une prostituée en Allemagne.
- Certains soldats
tentent leur chance.
- Il y en avait qui
cherchaient le contact.
C'était durant
leur grande promenade, mademoiselle.
Ils disaient cela
pour essayer d'entrer en relation,
ça marchait quelquefois.
- L'État major
voit pourtant d'un mauvais œil
tout contact
entre ses troupes et les Parisiens.
Il y a même des consignes
très fermes données aux soldats.
« Éviter tout contact
avec la population civile.
Il est interdit d'emmener des
Françaises dans une voiture de fonction
ou de les tenir par le bras. »
- Le soldat qui noue des liens
trop étroits avec la population civile
va finir par oublier
son rôle de soldat et ça,
c'est un gros
problème pour l'Armée.
- Paris avait le surnom
de la ville sans regard.
Les Allemands regardaient
les Françaises qui les ignoraient,
c'est intenable
sur une longue durée.
- Divisés par la guerre,
la langue et par la culture,
comment les nouveaux seigneurs
et les vaincus vont-ils vivre ensemble
dans ce Reich
de 1 000 ans promis par Hitler ?
Paris a de nombreux atouts
auxquels vont succomber les envahisseurs.
Fin de l'été 1940,
les soldats allemands ont pris possession
du cœur de Paris
et des terrasses de café,
mais pas seulement,
ils investissent aussi les magasins.
Paris en ce début d'occupation
est une véritable caverne d'Ali Baba.
- Les Allemands
avaient une frénésie de l'achat.
Ils achetaient des choses
qu'ils ne trouvaient pas chez eux,
comme des touristes.
Ils achetaient
tout ce qu'ils pouvaient.
Les Français disaient qu'on pouvait
même leur vendre une guêpière de 1870
et ils l'achetaient quand même.
- À partir du moment
où on n'est plus en guerre,
mais dans une
situation d'occupation,
la relation commerciale
qui s'établit est tout à fait classique.
Si un soldat
refuse de payer,
c'est du vol puni sévèrement
par le tribunal militaire allemand.
- Pour la première fois de leur vie,
les soldats ont des moyens.
Un salaire de 90 reichsmarks,
c'est l'équivalent du Smic aujourd'hui.
Sauf qu'avec un nouveau taux
de change favorable à l'occupant,
son pouvoir d'achat
est multiplié par quatre.
C'est uniquement
de l'argent de poche,
les soldats sont nourris,
logés aux frais de la France.
Ils découvrent alors
les joies du shopping.
- J'ai acheté du parfum,
ça s'appelait Soir de Paris.
Tous les soldats
achetaient ça à l'époque.
C'était un flacon
bleu avec des étoiles.
Franchement, je ne me souviens
même plus si ça sentait bon,
mais le flacon
était très joli.
- Il n'y avait pas un seul soldat
qui n'ait pas au moins une fois
envoyé des bas de soie
dans une lettre à sa petite amie,
c'était le grand luxe.
- Il fallait absolument
qu'on découvre les grands magasins,
Aux Trois Quartiers
et les Galeries Lafayette.
C'était une vraie
aventure pour nous.
Nous ne connaissions pas
les grands magasins comme ça.
On était habitués
au petit épicier du village.
Nous étions très contentes
de découvrir des fruits exotiques
qui venaient
de pays lointains.
Les bananes,
on n'en avait jamais mangé.
- Pour les officiers
qui touchent double solde,
c'est encore mieux.
Dans ces conditions,
quelques extras sont permis,
que du haut de gamme.
C'est le cas de cet officier,
Hans Lorenz.
Pendant quatre ans,
il n'aura qu'une obsession,
gâter son fils Peter,
resté au pays.
- J'avais les plus
beaux skis du monde,
un merveilleux vélo français
qu'on ne trouvait pas en Allemagne.
Il achetait
tout ça à Paris.
Mon père ramenait
aussi des parfums luxueux
et de grands crus
de Bourgogne et de Bordeaux.
Il avait
de la classe mon père,
il était comme
un coq en pâte à Paris.
- Ce n'est pas uniquement
sur les articles de luxe
que les Allemands
jettent leur dévolu.
Chose étonnante,
ils achètent de la nourriture
pour l'envoyer à la maison,
au cœur même
du Reich triomphant.
- Ils envoyaient même
des demi-cochons ou des œufs frais
emballés individuellement
dans des boites molletonnées.
Le soldat voulait remplir
son rôle d'homme et de père de famille
pour aider les siens
qui devaient se débrouiller seuls.
En étant loin de la maison,
tout ce qu'il pouvait
faire pour contribuer au foyer,
c'était d'envoyer
un maximum de produits.
Ça faisait partie en même
temps de la stratégie du Reich.
Plus les soldats envoyaient d'articles
achetés à bas prix dans les pays occupés,
moins il y avait
de pénurie en Allemagne.
- La France est une
réserve pour l'Allemagne
dans une guerre qui dure encore
et dont l'occupant
ne voit pas encore la fin en 1940.
Le but est donc d'exploiter
toutes les ressources de ce pays
pour continuer la guerre
contre l'Angleterre.
- Les envois deviennent tellement
nombreux que la Reichpost,
la poste du Reich,
est débordée.
Elle décide de limiter
le poids des colis par soldat.
Les nouveaux seigneurs se livrent
à un véritable pillage officiel.
Deux tiers de la production
française agricole et industrielle
sont réservés à l'occupant.
Un partage inégal
prévu par les conditions de l'armistice.
Les Parisiens connaissent alors
une véritable pénurie de nourriture,
mais aussi de carburant.
Un autre pillage
se poursuit plus discrètement.
Celui des œuvres d'art volées aux
grands collectionneurs Juifs parisiens,
notamment pour Göering et Hitler,
grands amateurs d'art.
- Göering est venu plus
de 20 fois et il est venu se servir.
Il y a donc la spoliation
des biens juifs bien évidemment,
et le vidage des appartements
qui ont appartenu à des Juifs,
des francs-maçons,
des Américains ou des Anglais.
Il y a eu le tri des objets et les plus
belles pièces sont mises de côté.
Effectivement,
c'est un pillage organisé et méthodique.
- Entre 1941 et 1944,
29 convois quittent Paris pour le Reich.
Ils représentent au total
138 wagons remplis de 4 170 caisses.
Le plus grand pillage
d'œuvres d'art de tous les temps.
Les Allemands
ne le savent pas encore,
mais la douceur de l'occupation
parisienne va bientôt toucher à sa fin.
22 juin 1941,
à 4 000 kilomètres de Paris,
les troupes de la Wehrmacht
envahissent l'Union soviétique.
Hitler lance
l'opération Barbarossa,
l'Europe s'embrase
à nouveau à l'Est.
Un tournant pour la guerre,
mais aussi pour Paris.
C'est le début
de la résistance armée.
À la station de métro
Barbès dans le 18ème,
Alfons Moser,
aspirant militaire de la Kriegsmarine,
est assassiné par balles
par Pierre Georges
plus connu sous son pseudonyme
de combattant, le colonel Fabien.
- Vers la fin
de l'année 1940,
la population se réveille
du choc de la défaite.
Les étudiants et lycéens manifestent
contre l'occupation sur les Champs-Élysées
le jour de l'armistice de 1918.
Ils se font arrêter
lors d'une opération jointe
entre les Français
et les Allemands.
Ce sont les premiers signes
indiquant que l'opinion
publique est en train de basculer.
- Cette manifestation
pacifique d'étudiants,
déclenche une répression féroce.
Manifestation ou attentat,
toute action anti-allemande
est passible de la peine de mort.
Une sentence prononcée
lors de procès fantoches.
Si les coupables
ne sont pas retrouvés,
la Wehrmacht applique des mesures
impitoyables dictées par Berlin.
- À partir du moment
où un membre de la Wehrmacht est tué
et d'autant plus
s'il s'agit d'un grade supérieur,
on établit un quota.
Cent otages
pour un Allemand tué.
- L'occupant fait connaître
ses sentences sur des affiches
imprimées
dans les deux langues.
À chaque fois,
des condamnations à mort.
L'objectif est simple,
faire régner la terreur.
- On craignait toujours quand on arrivait
dans la station de métro le matin,
qu'il y ait une affiche rouge
qui indiquait les noms des gens
que les Allemands
avaient fusillés.
Je me souviens
très bien d'avoir lu l'affiche
qui annonçait l'exécution
d'Estienne d'Orves.
- Le jeune capitaine de la Marine
française fait partie des 100 otages
exécutés suite
à l'attentat de Barbès.
- Ça faisait un peu peur aussi
et on ressentait la main de l'occupation.
Ça voulait bien dire
que c'était des gens qui résistent,
qui se battaient
contre les occupants.
- La Wehrmacht fait croire
aux soldats que derrière chaque homme
et surtout derrière chaque jolie femme,
se cache un ennemi du Reich.
Comment aller
contre la nature humaine
et frustrer toute une armée
de contacts sexuels ?
- Je peux vous dire
qu'une horde de jeunes hommes
avec les hormones en feu,
c'est de la dynamite.
C'est très dangereux,
il faut contenir tout ça.
- La solution, des maisons closes
réservées aux membres de la Wehrmacht.
Une initiative
encouragée par Adolf Hitler.
« Si on attend du soldat
qu'il donne sa vie sans réserve,
il doit aussi avoir la liberté
d'aimer sans réserve. »
- Des dizaines de maisons
closes sont alors réquisitionnées.
Gérants et prostituées sont français,
les femmes juives interdites.
Les maisons closes
pour les simples soldats
sont dans les quartiers populaires,
un plaisir impensable au Reich.
- Ce qui était interdit en Allemagne,
était autorisé en France.
Je ne sais pas
si c'est ça la liberté,
mais ça m'a permis de profiter
de choses que je n'avais pas chez moi,
comme les maisons
closes par exemple.
- Dans une lettre
adressée à sa femme,
le soldat Günther raconte
le fonctionnement des maisons closes
et il est plutôt prudent.
« Ma chérie, je n'y suis pas allé.
Il faut dire que ces personnes
ne sont vraiment pas à mon goût.
Les statistiques disent
qu'une prostituée assure en moyenne
100 passes par jour,
le record étant de 187.
Imagine dans quel état elles
doivent être. Bonjour le spectacle. »
Puis il y a les maisons
closes réservées aux officiers,
comme le Chabanais,
à deux pas du Palais Royal.
Une institution déjà
légendaire à la belle époque
où le très fameux et très moderne,
One-Two-Two, situé rue de Provence.
Des maisons closes haut
de gamme avec des intérieurs luxueux.
Des salles
de bains orientales
et un mobilier
qui laisse place à tous les fantasmes.
Les femmes attendent les clients
dans des boudoirs au décor sulfureux.
Habillées ou pas,
elles sont triées sur le volet.
Les Allemands
sont obsédés par l'hygiène.
Le vrai ennemi de la Wehrmacht,
les maladies vénériennes.
- Paris a une réputation
de ville de plaisirs.
À tort ou à raison,
peut-être plutôt à raison.
Une réputation aussi, de ville sale
et la notion de sanitaires
ne sont pas les mêmes.
Les Allemands découvrent que les
Français ne se lavent pas tous les jours,
donc cette idée
de la femme dangereuse,
de la femme vénale
et de la maladie vénérienne.
- La syphilis n'est pas
une maladie curable à l'époque.
Alors, les maisons closes
comme le Chabanais,
sont équipées
d'un cabinet gynécologique
où les filles sont contrôlées
deux fois par semaine.
Ce n'est pas tout.
Les soldats aussi subissent des
contrôles et des traitements préventifs.
Sur les listes distribuées,
figurent à gauche
les adresses des maisons closes
et à droite celles
des officines de désinfection.
Les soldats doivent s'y rendre
avant et après chaque rapport.
Dans une telle ambiance,
les choses dérapent facilement.
Un soldat mécontent et c'est l'expédition
punitive dans une maison close.
« Il fallait leur montrer
qui étaient les seigneurs.
On ne pouvait
pas laisser passer ça.
On est rentré dans la maison close,
on a tiré un peu dans tous les sens
et on est
monté voir la prostitué.
On l'a déshabillée, jeté ses affaires
par la fenêtre et on l'a tabassée.
Les gens nous
ont juste regardé faire.
C'était notre vengeance,
on était au sommet de notre pouvoir. »
- Certains soldats
font régner la terreur.
Le soldat autrichien
Heinz se souvient.
« S'ils ont fini par nous détester,
c'est bien de notre faute.
On était arrogants.
Pendant les patrouilles,
on vérifiait si les gens
respectaient bien le couvre-feu
et si les rideaux
étaient bien tirés.
Quand on voyait de la lumière,
les officiers tiraient dans les fenêtres.
C'est à cause
de ce genre de choses
que les gens ont
fini par nous détester. »
Enjeu pour l'État major,
éviter à tout prix ces dérapages.
En plein Paris,
l'occupant a refait l'Allemagne.
Dans les quartiers les plus prestigieux,
il y a deux librairies allemandes,
rue de Rivoli
et sur les Champs-Élysées.
Trois salles de cinéma
ont été réquisitionnées,
deux sur les Champs-Élysées et le Rex
avec une immense salle de 2000 places.
Au menu, des films allemands,
des comptines romantiques,
mais aussi
de la propagande pure et simple.
- Il fallait reconstituer une partie
de l'Allemagne pour ces soldats,
leur donner un havre de paix.
Le grand défi était de
les occuper et de les contenir.
Par exemple, il fallait qu'ils
puissent fêter Noël à l'allemande.
On devait leur permettre
de vivre un peu comme au pays,
c'était très important.
- En plus, Paris compte
plusieurs foyers de soldats.
Les plus importants
se trouvent place de Clichy,
à Saint-Michel
et sur les Champs-Élysées.
Sous le portrait du Führer, on y sert
de la nourriture typiquement allemande,
soupe à la carotte,
du poisson frit accompagné
de crudités et de pommes de terre.
Le tout dans une ambiance
typiquement allemande.
- On peut avoir plaisir
à se retrouver entre soi
et un peu à l'allemande aussi.
C'est-à-dire un endroit
où on peut prendre un café,
manger un gâteau,
lire les journaux allemands,
les librairies allemandes
et tout ça est très pensé.
- Dans ces endroits,
il y avait encore à manger.
Dans les brasseries parisiennes,
il n'y avait plus grand-chose.
La carte était réduite alors
que là bas, il y avait du choix.
- Au luxueux foyer des aviateurs
sur le boulevard de Courcelles,
on trouve même une brasserie
bavaroise fidèlement reconstituée.
De quoi leur faire
oublier le mal du pays.
Dans les lettres
du soldat Kurt à sa fiancée Dorit,
on lit : « Le café
et les gâteaux sont vraiment bons
et le dîner
n'était pas mal non plus.
Ensuite, on s'est défoulé
en jouant au ping-pong
et quand j'ai vu
la petite serveuse française,
j'ai cru que c'était toi,
mon petit cœur.
Je me suis senti très seul,
j'aimerais tant être avec toi. »
Puis il y a le café des Soldats Madeleine,
à deux pas de la célèbre église.
Le plus luxueux,
le plus couru aussi.
Le responsable des loisirs
de la Wehrmacht est Heinz Lorenz,
l'officier qui envoyait les vélos
dernier cri à son fils en Allemagne.
Dans ses mémoires,
il décrit l'ambiance de ces endroits.
« Le café était pris d'assaut,
c'était effrayant.
Tout ce qu'ils voulaient,
c'était manger un gâteau
et oublier la guerre
pendant un petit moment.
Les soldats étaient
obsédés par les sucreries.
Ce qu'on servait n'était sûrement
pas de la haute gastronomie.
De la farine de mauvaise qualité,
un peu de lait et beaucoup de sucre.
L'essentiel était la décoration
et le sourire des serveuses.
En un seul weekend,
on a vendu 22 000 de ces gâteaux. »
Infatigable, l'officier Lorenz
se démène pour offrir des distractions
en tout genre aux soldats.
- Il organisait des compétitions sportives
de véritables petits Jeux olympiques.
Des compétitions d'athlétisme,
des courses à pied, du saut en hauteur.
Bref, il y avait
toutes les disciplines.
- J'ai fait beaucoup de sport,
surtout de la natation.
Une piscine nous a été
réservée où j'allais très souvent.
J'en ai profité
pour passer mon brevet de secourisme.
Puis le football,
le sport national en Allemagne.
La Wehrmacht
organise un championnat.
La Luftwaffe, armée de l'air
contre la Panzerdivision,
la division blindée
et à chaque fois au Parc des Princes.
C'est toujours
les Allemands qui gagnent.
Hans Lorenz
va même solliciter les artistes
parmi les soldats pour
des concours de peinture et de dessin.
De drôles de peintres en uniforme
vont alors installer leurs chevalets
dans les coins les plus pittoresques
de Paris comme Montmartre.
Le résultat
est parfois surprenant.
Comme ces petits
dessins du soldat Schmitz
qui mettent
en scène ses fantasmes.
Pas sûr
que le Führer aurait approuvé.
- Ils voulaient
occuper les soldats.
Leur permettre de vivre
des choses extraordinaires
et c'est pour ça
qu'on a organisé ces concours de peinture.
Parmi les soldats,
il y avait de véritables artistes.
- Son père
ne manque pas d'imagination.
Il va même faire
retaper une vieille péniche
pour offrir aux soldats
des croisières sur la Seine.
Tous les jours, 200 d'entre
eux embarquent sur le Touriste II,
reconnaissable bien sûr
à son drapeau à croix gammée.
Le seul bateau civil
autorisé à circuler sur la Seine.
Au programme, flonflons, ballades
romantiques et jolies accompagnatrices.
Les balades en bateau
sont promotionnées dans
des guides allemands publiés à Paris.
Le plus célèbre d'entre
eux est le Der Deutsche Wegleiter,
le pariscope allemand
spécialement conçu pour les troupes.
Plan de métro,
programmes culturels parisiens,
programme de la Wehrmacht.
Tout est fait pour que le soldat allemand
s'y retrouve dans la grande métropole.
- Ce guide devient aussi très important
pour les commerçants parisiens
parce qu'ils peuvent
y mettre des annonces.
Des studios photos
proposent de faire des portraits chez eux.
Des institutions comme
le Lido et d'autres cabarets
font de la publicité
pour leurs programmes,
parfois aussi en couleur.
Le cinéma, le théâtre,
la vie culturelle en général
reprennent assez rapidement.
Les Allemands
y participent très activement
aussi grâce
à ce genre de guide.
- En quelques mois,
le Wigleiter passe
de 16 à plus de 100 pages.
Les annonceurs parisiens
se bousculent au portillon.
Des annonces
en allemand, bien sûr.
Salons de mode,
fourrures, meubles,
affaires pour bébés
et aussi les restaurants.
À Montmartre, l'un des quartiers
les plus prisés par l'occupant,
le plus célèbre des restaurants
s'appelle La Mère Catherine
situé place du Tertre.
Il affiche
complet tous les jours.
Pour cause,
le patron de ce petit bistrot parisien
a adapté sa carte
au goût de l'occupant.
Les goûts culinaires français
et allemands sont différents.
Par exemple,
les allemands n'aiment pas
les mollusques et les fruits de mer,
alors que c'est délectable
pour les français.
Ça, ce n'est pas consommé
et tant mieux pour les Français
qui peuvent manger quelque chose.
Au menu chez La Mère Catherine,
saucisse de Strasbourg à six francs.
Chose étonnante,
certaines habitudes alimentaires
de l'occupant vont s'installer
dans la gastronomie française.
Les carottes râpées,
ça peut paraître un peu étrange,
mais ça n'existait pas
avant l'arrivée de l'occupant.
On s'est mis à manger
des carottes râpées en France occupée,
avec avec l'occupant
et d'ailleurs on continue.
Les plus audacieux des soldats
vont essayer la cuisine française,
totalement exotique pour eux.
Voici la lettre d'un soldat
qui a décidé de se lancer
dans des aventures culinaires locales.
Ma chère et tendre femme,
je voudrais te raconter quelque
chose qui te fera beaucoup rire.
Figure-toi que j'ai essayé
pour la première fois des escargots
et je dois dire que c'était bon.
J'ai fermé les yeux
en mangeant le premier.
L'aspect et le goût
ressemblent un peu aux rognons.
Je pourrais
en remanger tous les jours.
Paris était la ville
des premières fois.
Une des femmes m'avait racontée
qu'elle avait découvert le chocolat chaud,
elle n'en avait
jamais bu avant.
Elles ont appris
à boire du champagne,
de l'alcool et même de l'absinthe
que certaines buvaient dans les bars.
Les officiers
et l'État major de leur côté,
vivent comme des nababs.
Témoin ce menu
servi lors d'un dîner de gala à l'Opéra.
Au menu, huîtres, bouchées à la reine,
filets de sole à la Brillat-Savarin,
poulet en cocotte aux champignons
et pommes dauphines
et pour finir en légèreté,
omelette norvégienne.
Pendant que la population parisienne
compte ses tickets de rationnement,
les grandes tables prisées par l'occupant
regorgent de produits introuvables.
Comme chez Maxim's, l'adresse
la plus prestigieuse de la capitale,
la cantine préférée
d'Hermann Göring.
Arno Breker,
sculpteur préféré du Führer,
habitué du lieu,
écrira plus tard.
Maxim's était une fête
pour les yeux et le palais,
comme je n'en ai jamais vu
ni avant ni après l'occupation.
1941, alors qu'à Paris
l'ambiance était à la fête,
en Europe de l'Est, les nazis commencent
à rafler les populations juives.
C'est le début de la solution finale,
l'extermination des juifs d'Europe.
Comme sur ces images
terrifiantes tournées en Lettonie
par les bourreaux eux mêmes.
L'organisateur de ces massacres
débarque à Paris en mai 1942.
C'est Reinhard Heydrich,
chef des SS, des escadrons de sécurité.
Heydrich rencontre ici René Bousquet,
à gauche dans l'image,
chef de la Police française.
C'est elle qui va faire le sale boulot.
Les Français se disent
que s'ils faisaient les choses eux mêmes,
ils gardaient une certaine autonomie
et un certain contrôle du pays.
Comme le gouvernement
de Vichy est d'accord avec les Allemands
sur le fond des choses,
les lois anti-juives et les persécutions,
il n'y a pas
vraiment de problème.
Première mesure,
le décret du 7 juin 1942.
Il oblige les Juifs parisiens
à porter l'étoile jaune,
83 000 étoiles sont distribuées
dans les commissariats parisiens
à raison
de trois par personne.
Comble du cynisme, ils doivent les
payer avec des tickets de rationnement.
Cette mesure
marque profondément les Parisiens.
- Alors là, j'ai un souvenir très
net d'avoir vu un vieux monsieur
qui avait la Légion d'honneur
et c'était un avocat.
Il avait donc sa robe d'avocat,
la légion d'honneur
et une étoile jaune.
Je dois dire
que j'étais surpris et ému.
Ému de voir cette ségrégation,
cette ségrégation raciale
qui ne correspondait en rien.
Il fallait qu'ils montent obligatoirement
dans le dernier wagon du métro.
Je me souviens
que moi et d'autres,
on montait aussi
dans ce wagon-là.
C'était un peu
de solidarité pour eux.
Ce qui était
dangereux, finalement.
On ne savait pas que
si jamais on venait rafler les Juifs
qui étaient dans ce wagon,
on était raflés avec eux.
- Juillet 1942.
Les nazis annoncent
vouloir déporter 100 000 juifs de France.
Alors les autorités
françaises s'exécutent.
Le 16 juillet,
c'est la rafle du Vél' d'Hiv,
13 152 femmes,
hommes et enfants,
sont arrêtés puis déportés
vers les camps de la mort.
Seulement trois pourcent
d'entre eux reviendront vivants.
- La France entre à ce moment-là
comme un véritable homme de main
dans le programme
allemand de la solution finale.
Entre 1942 et 1944,
50 000 juifs parisiens seront fusillés
ou déportés vers les camps de la mort.
Ce sont les heures les plus
noires que connaîtra la Ville lumière
pendant l'occupation nazie.
Automne 1942.
Deux ans que les Allemands profitent
de la douceur de vivre à la parisienne.
Gertrud,
la petite opératrice de la Wehrmacht,
a maintenant
ses coins préférés.
- Au jardin du Luxembourg,
j'ai toujours trouvé
quelqu'un pour discuter.
Quand on voyait
des petits enfants,
on parlait aux mères
et c'était vraiment très agréable.
- Elle part à l'aventure
sur les hauteurs de Montmartre.
Intriguée par ces artistes locaux,
elle prend son courage à deux mains
et engage la conversation
avec l'un d'entre eux.
- J'ai parlé avec un peintre.
J'ai voulu savoir
s'il arrivait à vivre de son métier,
il a fini par me faire
un dessin du Sacré-Cœur pour moi
et il a même
écrit mon nom dessus.
- Cette idylle est trompeuse,
la résistance parisienne ne dort pas.
Le 16 septembre 1942,
un premier attentat a lieu devant le
foyer pour soldats sur les Champs-Élysées.
La bombe artisanale cachée
à l'entrée du métro explose trop tôt.
Elle rate alors
de quelques minutes les soldats
qui devaient sortir
du cinéma juste à côté.
Seulement 24 heures plus tard,
une autre bombe
explose devant le Grand Rex
quand environ 2 000 soldats
sortent d'une séance.
Cette fois-ci,
elle fait quatre morts et 17 blessés.
La réponse allemande,
plusieurs dizaines d'otages
fusillés en guise de représailles.
Heinz Lorentz,
qui se trouvait dans la foule,
commentera ces événements
dans ses mémoires.
« Je pense que le but
recherché par la résistance
n'était pas forcément
de tuer des soldats allemands,
mais de diviser
les Allemands et les Français.
C'est ce qu'ils ont réussi à faire. »
Ce genre d'actions
ne reste pas sans incidence
sur le quotidien
des soldats allemands.
Ils ne sont plus autorisés à sortir seuls
et le port d'armes devient obligatoire.
La vigilance est désormais de mise.
- Il fallait faire attention,
notamment dans le métro.
Il y avait
des endroits dangereux.
Si on s'approchait trop du bord du quai,
on risquait d'être poussé sur les voies.
- Il ne faut pas croire que
la résistance a traumatisé les soldats.
Les Allemands,
ce sont eux les professionnels.
Les services
secrets et la Sipo-SD
ont été formés
pour débusquer des opposants politiques.
De l'autre côté,
vous avez par exemple un petit instituteur
qui décide d'entrer en résistance,
d'imprimer un tract et qui se retrouve
complètement démuni face à la répression.
Au début,
les petits groupes de résistants
qui se forment
ont beaucoup de difficultés.
Une petite information suffit
pour faire tomber tout un réseau.
- Paris sera toujours Paris,
ce n'est pas la Résistance
qui empêchera les soldats de s'amuser.
Les incontournables Lido,
Moulin Rouge, Folies Bergère
qui sont pris
d'assaut tous les soirs.
Le plus typique aux yeux de l'occupant,
le Sheherazade,
rue de Liège,
dans le neuvième arrondissement.
Ces spectacles fascinent le soldat Lenz
qui écrit à sa femme restée à Vienne.
« Le décor de la revue
était un délice pour les yeux,
ainsi que les scènes
et les accessoires artistiques.
Jeux de plaisanteries, chansons
et femmes dans de multiples costumes,
si on peut
encore appeler cela ainsi.
L'une des pièces était pour nous
faire plaisir, les Valses de Vienne.
On a joué cette belle
musique du Beau Danube bleu.
Tu peux imaginer que malgré
mon enthousiasme pour la revue,
ces tonalités
m'ont fait un peu mal au cœur. »
- Les nuits parisiennes
permettent aux soldats
de profiter de ce que le Reich
considère comme de l'art dégénéré.
Le swing, musique de l'ennemi américain
strictement interdite en Allemagne.
Les soldats raffolent aussi des orchestres
Tziganes et de Django Reinhardt.
Au même moment,
le Reich déporte des milliers
de Rom dans les camps de concentration.
- Les Allemands
sont très friands de ces spectacles
et parfois il y a de véritables
bagarres entre soldats et public français
pour les meilleures
places dans les salles.
Des stars françaises
comme Maurice Chevalier,
Mistinguett, Fernandel,
Arletty et Sacha Guitry
se produisent
devant l'occupant.
Ils deviennent ainsi
les chouchous du public allemand.
- Dans cette guerre,
Paris n'est pas une cible militaire.
Ici, vous avez vraiment
une situation d'exception
et vous pouvez passer des permissions
encore plus agréables qu'à la maison.
- À des milliers de kilomètres de Paris,
les combats font rage.
Le front a besoin d'hommes et Klaus,
le soldat berlinois,
rejoint l'AfrikaKorps
de Rommel en Tunisie.
D'autres soldats arrivent
directement des champs de bataille,
Paris est la récompense
ultime pour leurs sacrifices.
L'un d'entre eux
s'appelle Gisbert Witte.
Ce transmetteur dans
l'Armée de l'air, âgé de 22 ans,
souffre depuis toujours
d'un problème de reins.
Gravement malade,
Gisbert est alors envoyé
en convalescence à Paris.
Il échappe pour quelques
semaines au champ de bataille
et il entend bien en profiter.
- À chaque nouvelle mutation,
la première chose
qui intéressait mon père,
c'était le programme culturel.
- Pas question
de rester enfermé à l'hôpital.
Avec deux autres
camarades soldats comme lui,
Gisbert explore Paris.
Leur rêve à tous,
c'est d'aller à l'opéra.
Seuls les uniformes d'officiers
ou les queues de pie sont admis.
Gisbert et ses amis
vont alors échafauder un plan.
- Le troisième de la bande
était serveur dans le mess des officiers.
Il a donc emprunté pour la soirée
des queues de pie au vestiaire.
Il a trouvé
les bonnes tailles.
Les trois les ont
enfilés, ils ont fait le mur
et c'est comme ça
qu'ils ont passé quelques bonnes soirées.
Mon père m'a dit plus tard qu'il ne
savait pas ce qu'ils auraient fait d'eux
s'ils s'étaient faits prendre.
Pourtant,
ils l'ont fait plusieurs fois.
- L'Opéra, l'Opéra comique,
la salle Pleyel,
partout des contingents
de places sont réservées aux troupes
et le commandant
de Paris a bien sûr sa loge.
- Au théâtre Hébertot,
aux vestiaires,
il y avait des rangées
de casquettes d'officier allemand.
J'ai été épaté
en me disant que
ce n'était pas
un spectacle de danseuses nues,
c'était vraiment
un spectacle intellectuel.
Qu'il y ait autant d'Allemands
qui parlent bien français
et qui s'intéressent à la vie
intellectuelle française, j'imagine.
- Les Allemands veulent
aussi montrer aux Parisiens
qu'ils sont une grande
nation de culture.
On fait venir
ce que le Reich a de meilleur,
la Philharmonie de Berlin
sous la direction d'Herbert Von Karajan.
Ça se passe
au Théâtre de Chaillot,
réquisitionné trois soirs par semaine
pour assurer une programmation allemande.
Plus modestement,
Gertrud participe aussi
au rapprochement entre les peuples
avec la chorale
protestante de la Wehrmacht.
En 1942,
à l'occasion des fêtes de Noël,
elle chante la Passion
de Bach à Notre-Dame.
Au même moment,
les bombes tombent sur Berlin,
Hambourg et Munich.
- Quand je rentrais
en Allemagne en permission
et que je parlais
de mes aventures parisiennes,
de la chorale,
de notre concert à Notre-Dame.
Mon père me demandait
si on ne connaissait donc pas la guerre.
S'ils vivaient vraiment
comme en temps de paix.
- À Paris, la ville d'exception,
la guerre épargne les soldats.
Alors Gisbert,
l'amateur d'opéra,
va tout faire pour éviter
de retourner sur les champs de bataille.
- Il savait qu'une fois
ses soins finis,
il serait obligé
de retourner sur le front russe.
Alors, avec l'un de ses amis
qui avait des connaissances médicales,
ils ont décidé de fabriquer
un mélange d'urine et de sang
pour pouvoir convaincre
les médecins de la gravité de sa maladie.
Grâce à cela,
il n'a pas été renvoyé sur le front.
À nous, ses enfants,
il a toujours dit
que ça lui avait sauvé la vie.
Il faut savoir qu'aucun homme de
son unité n'est rentré vivant de Russie.
- Paris reste pour l'instant
le refuge privilégié des troupes,
mais pour combien
de temps encore ?
1943,
l'année du tournant.
À Stalingrad, les soldats
allemands tombent comme des mouches
où sont faits prisonniers
par centaines de milliers.
Pour la première fois,
les Parisiens sentent que le vent tourne.
La presse
est contrôlée par l'occupant
et les journaux
ne rapportent que des faits glorieux.
Alors les Parisiens doivent chercher
les informations à la BBC anglaise.
- On se mettait sur radio Londres
et on faisait très attention.
On ne mettait ça pas trop fort,
toujours dans la crainte
que quelqu'un d'autre l'entende, etc.
Il est arrivé que les Allemands
rentrent dans les maisons
et immédiatement, allument
la radio pour voir ce qu'on écoutait.
S'ils retombaient sur Radio Londres,
les gens qui écoutaient Radio Londres
commençaient à avoir des ennuis.
- Les Français se rebellent
discrètement contre l'occupant.
Pour preuve,
ces affiches de la collaboration,
Combat contre le bolchévisme
devient après quelques coups
de pinceau, combat contre le Boche.
Les Parisiens choisissent les affiches
dans le métro pour faire de même.
- Étant qu'il est interdit
de fumer dans le métro
et on avait mis
des affiches dans chaque wagon,
Rauchen Verboten,
interdiction de fumer.
Les Français ont remarqué
qu'en coupant quelques lettres,
il pouvait subsister,
Race verte.
C'était les Allemands,
ils étaient habillés en vert.
- Si l'ambiance se tend,
les Allemands n'ont pas
que des ennemis en France.
En trois ans de présence
au contact quotidien avec les civils,
d'occupants, certains sont passés
à amis, voire même amants.
L'officier Heintz Lorenz
s'affiche sans sourciller
avec ses plus jolies
conquêtes parisiennes.
- Mes parents menaient
une relation très ouverte.
Mon père était
un véritable homme à femmes.
Tous les deux
n'ont laissé passer aucune occasion.
Ils vivaient leur vie
chacun de leur côté.
- L'amour entre Françaises et soldats
allemands est une chose impensable.
Pourtant,
de la haine à l'indifférence,
de la cohabitation pacifique
aux amitiés et du sexe à l'amour,
la nature humaine
fait son œuvre.
Début avril 1943,
une jeune Bretonne
de 24 ans débarque à Paris.
Marguerite Rouxel
a un gros problème.
Elle porte l'enfant d'Otto Ammon,
un sous-officier
Allemand de l'Armée de l'air.
Si elle vient à Paris,
c'est pour accoucher
à la clinique du Port Royal.
Un régime spécial
permet aux femmes d'accoucher
dans l'anonymat
sous un faux nom.
Le fruit de cette union interdite,
le petit Daniel, un enfant de l'amour.
- Mon père a aimé
très sincèrement ma mère,
ma mère a toujours aimé mon père
et elle en était folle.
Ma mère était à la maison
et je mets à la télévision
une photo de mon père.
Elle n'était pas au courant.
Elle vient à l'improviste
et elle regarde : « Otto, Otto ».
On aurait dit une jeune fille
qui retrouve son amoureux.
C'est quelque chose qui est...
Elle pleurait et elle pleurait.
Oui, une très belle histoire.
- Cette histoire entre Otto
et Mathilde commence en Bretagne,
sur les routes de Saint-Malo où ils
se rencontrent pour la première fois.
- Elle se promenait en vélo
sur la route de Saint-Malo,
ça devait être son jour de congé.
Elle a rencontré mon père
qui était avec une voiture
et son camarade.
Ils ont arrêté la voiture
et ils ont parlé avec ma mère.
Mon père avait un petit détail
qui m'avait beaucoup amusé,
il mangeait des cerises.
Mon père avait offert
des cerises à ma mère.
- Mathilde trouve un travail comme
cantinière dans une caserne où vit Otto.
Les amoureux
passent du temps ensemble.
Des deux côtés,
l'entourage est au courant,
mais on ferme les yeux.
Les problèmes arrivent
quand Daniel vient au monde.
- Mon père est monté à Paris pour me voir,
il n'a pas eu le droit d'entrer.
Il n'a pas eu le droit
d'entrer dans la clinique.
- Les Allemands n'ont pas le droit
de reconnaître ces enfants-là
et de se marier
avec les Françaises.
Tout ça était interdit
par la Wehrmacht.
- Otto ne verra son fils qu'une seule
fois pour le serrer dans ses bras.
- Il a dit à sa mère
qu'il avait un fils en France,
S'il devait mourir, il voulait que
je sois élevé comme il avait été élevé.
- La guerre fait son œuvre
et l'unité d'Otto doit quitter la France.
C'est à quatre ans que
Daniel apprend qui est son père.
- Je suis allé
dans une rentrée à l'école.
Ils ne me connaissaient pas
et ils sont venus me voir
en me disant
que j'étais le fils de Boche.
Qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ?
Qu'est ce que c'est ?
Puis que ma mère
avait fait un boche.
Que des mots,
les plus absurdes,
les plus mauvais
qu'on a entendus.
Je n'avais qu'une envie, c'est de pleurer
et de ne plus retourner à l'école.
- Être l'enfant de l'ennemi,
un stigmate que Daniel
portera toute sa vie.
Sous la pression de l'entourage,
la belle histoire entre Otto et Mathilde
se transforme en cauchemar
pour la mère et son enfant.
- Ma mère était très gênée.
J'étais une vraie
gêne pour ma mère.
Elle avait une honte
qu'elle ne pouvait pas...
Il y avait toujours quelqu'un
qui était là aussi pour lui rappeler,
toujours quelqu'un.
- Aujourd'hui encore,
difficile de déterminer
le nombre exact d'enfants
issus de relations
entre Françaises et Allemands.
Les estimations
vont de 60 à 200 000.
Autant d'histoires d'amour
cachées vécues dans la honte.
6 juin 1944,
jour du débarquement
sur les plages de Normandie.
Américains, Anglais
et Canadiens ouvrent le front de l'Ouest
pour encercler
l'Allemagne d'Hitler.
Maintenant, la guerre fait rage
à 250 kilomètres de Paris.
Pour la première
fois en quatre ans,
Gertrud en voit les conséquences,
d'opératrice, elle devient infirmière.
- Il fallait qu'on les soigne,
qu'on fasse des pansements,
des soins
de premiers secours.
Il y en avait
plus d'un qui mourrait.
- À Paris, le haut commandement
fait pourtant comme si de rien n'était.
Les consignes qui viennent
de Berlin sont claires, pas de panique.
Il faut inspirer
la confiance aux Parisiens,
mais dans les coulisses,
on s'active.
- À cette époque-là,
début août 1944,
l'État major
se pose la question du retrait,
mais on n'envisage pas
le retour en Allemagne.
Ensuite, on commence
à brûler des dossiers systématiquement.
L'été 1944 est décrit
comme étant très enneigé
avec les bouts
de cendre qui retombaient.
- Les événements
vont se précipiter.
Le 19 août, les premiers
combats éclatent dans les rues.
C'est le début
de l'insurrection des Parisiens.
Une totale surprise pour Gertrud
et pour la première fois, elle a peur.
- On n'était plus en sécurité
dans les rues, ça tirait de partout.
Là,
c'était vraiment la guerre.
- Seule possibilité,
prendre la fuite.
Certains l'ont déjà fait,
comme l'officier Lorenz.
Grâce à ses amis parisiens,
il a trouvé un chauffeur
qui l'a conduit jusqu'en Allemagne.
Pour de simples soldats,
rien n'est prévu,
car pour Hitler,
la défaite n'a jamais été une option.
- L'Allemand est forcément victorieux
parce que c'est une race supérieure.
À ce moment-là, le bon soldat
est celui qui meurt au combat
pour défendre
sa patrie ou qui est victorieux.
- Les 20 000 soldats
sont alors livrés à eux-mêmes.
Leurs options sont minces,
en ce mois d'août 1944 le train est exclu.
Les chemins de fer ont été
sabotés par la Résistance française.
Gertrud n'a que quelques
heures pour trouver une solution.
- Nul ne s'est soucié
de nous pour nous faire sortir de Paris.
On a pris le dernier métro,
mes copines et moi et nous
sommes allées jusqu'au terminus.
Là-bas, il y avait encore
quelques camions allemands
déjà abîmés
par des impacts de balles.
L'un d'entre eux
nous a emmenées.
Sur la route, on devait s'arrêter
plusieurs fois pour se cacher.
On nous tirait dessus.
C'était horrible.
Je me demande
comment on a survécu à ça.
- Pour Gertrud, la première étape
est Verdun puis les Pays-Bas.
Pour elle,
la guerre continue.
À l'hôtel Meurice,
le nouveau commandant
de Paris, Dietrich Von Choltitz,
reçoit un ordre de Berlin,
défendre la ville coûte que coûte
jusqu'au dernier homme,
il va miner les endroits stratégiques,
centre téléphonique,
le Sénat et le pont Alexandre III.
Tout est en place pour que Paris
devienne un champ de bataille.
Seul problème, la plupart des soldats
sont partis sur le front de Normandie.
- Les Allemands
essaient à la dernière minute
de rassembler
des unités de fortune.
C'est là qu'on
s'est rendu compte
que parmi les 20 000 soldats
qui étaient encore à Paris,
très peu avaient
une vraie formation militaire.
Ils étaient pour la plupart
des fonctionnaires en uniforme,
mais pas des soldats.
- 23 août.
La deuxième DB du général
Leclerc est à 50 kilomètres de Paris.
Rien ne peut l'arrêter.
Alors Von Choltitz sait que
défendre Paris est peine perdu.
Il négocie même
un cessez le feu avec la résistance.
À Berlin,
on reste sans information.
Alors Hitler se fend d'un télégramme
avec cette question devenue célèbre,
Paris brûle-t-il ?
- Ce n'était pas
un ordre de destruction.
Von Choltitz a arrangé la vérité
dans ses mémoires après la guerre
parce qu'il pensait que
les Français voulaient entendre ça.
Il n'avait aucun
intérêt à informer Berlin
qu'il avait négocié
un armistice avec la Résistance.
Ça pouvait être considéré
comme de la haute trahison.
- Il s'est comporté davantage en soldat
qu'en nazi en disant que c'était fini,
qu'il valait mieux
préserver et Paris et les troupes
que d'aller au combat
jusqu'au bout et qui était une défaite.
- Le 24 août vers 18 heures,
les premiers blindés
français du général Leclerc
arrivent à Paris devant l'Hôtel de ville,
déjà pris par la Résistance.
- Tout d'un coup, on a entendu
sonner les cloches des églises.
Ce jour-là, la radio était passée
entre les mains de la Résistance.
Le speaker répétait en demandant
à messieurs les curés de Paris
de bien vouloir faire sonner leurs
églises pour la libération de la Capitale.
C'était vraiment tout chaud,
ça se passait en ce moment-là.
On a entendu petit à petit
toutes les églises alentour
se mettre à sonner, etc.
c'était très émouvant.
- Le lendemain, le 25 août 1944,
les combats font rage.
Ils sont particulièrement violents
autour des points stratégiques allemands,
la Kommandantur,
le Majestic et l'École militaire.
Plus de 1 000 Français et
3 200 Allemands vont y laisser leur vie.
L'une après l'autre,
les forteresses allemandes vont tomber.
Le Meurice
est l'une des premières,
c'est ici que Von Choltitz
signe la reddition,
précisément à 14 h 45.
- Ensuite, il devait aussi
signer des ordres de reddition
qui étaient délivrés
par des officiers allemands
accompagnés de soldats
Français ou alliés
aux différents points
de résistance allemande.
- Paris est libérée.
Ces images de scènes
de liesse font le tour du monde,
ainsi que celles
des anciens seigneurs allemands déchus.
Près de 13 000 d'entre
eux seront faits prisonniers.
L'inversion des rôles
pour les Parisiens, tout un symbole.
- L'Allemand qui a défilé
de la Concorde jusqu'aux Champs-Élysées.
Cette armée victorieuse devient une armée,
donc défaite et inversement,
les vaincus d'hier
deviennent les vainqueurs d'aujourd'hui.
- Les Parisiens
n'ont pas oublié l'occupation,
les pénuries,
les rafles et la répression.
Voir l'ancien occupant en
situation de vaincu est un soulagement
qui incite parfois
à des débordements.
- Il y a des scènes
de soldats qui vont être insultés,
qui vont être un peu molestés,
à qui on va envoyer insultes et crachats.
Il y a vraiment une violence
mesurée qui est verbale et physique,
mais qui est une
violence de défoulement.
C'est vraiment
la population civile
et on voit que
ce ne sont pas que des hommes,
mais des femmes
ou des enfants qui se vengent.
Même si cela est mesuré,
ils se vengent de cette occupation
ou de cet vainqueur qui est maintenant
vaincu et qui est sans défense.
- Pour ces soldats,
la guerre est maintenant finie.
D'occupants,
ils deviennent prisonniers.
Un nouveau statut peint sur leur uniforme,
PG, pour prisonniers de guerre.
Les 800 000 prisonniers
de guerre allemands
seront réquisitionnés
pour déminer les plages
et travailler
dans les mines du Nord.
Les derniers d'entre eux
rentreront en 1948.
Gertrud est arrivée saine
et sauve en Allemagne.
Elle est retournée
dans sa région d'origine,
s'est mariée
et a eu trois enfants.
Elle vit aujourd'hui dans une maison
de retraite dans le Nord de l'Allemagne.
Klaus,
le soldat de la première heure,
a passé quatre années
en captivité aux États-Unis.
Retour en 1948
après huit années d'absence,
il vit aujourd'hui à Berlin.
Le soldat Gisbert
est rentré en Allemagne,
il a ouvert un magasin
d'électroménager à Kronenbourg.
La musique
est restée sa passion.
Depuis sa mort en 2014,
sa fille garde précieusement
ses photos souvenirs de Paris.
L'officier Hans Lorenz
a retrouvé son fils.
Jusqu'à sa mort en 1966,
il a continué d'organiser
des événements culturels
comme la Fête
du vin en Allemagne.
Quant à Daniel Rouxel,
l'enfant de Boche,
il rencontrera sa famille
allemande à l'âge de 12 ans.
En 2009, après des années
de tracas administratifs,
il a obtenu
la double nationalité allemande.
Il s'appelle désormais
Daniel Rouxel-Ammon.
À Paris, plus aucune trace ne rappelle
les années noires de l'occupation.
La fascination des Allemands
pour la Ville lumière est restée intacte.